[Music]
dino here
in the prior videos in this series we
learned the how and why
of api proxies and api products
in this video we'll learn about the api
portal
the apigee edge developer portal is the
best way to connect developers who use
apis
to the apis you've created it includes
an elegant web experience clear
interactive api documentation
and a self-service way to get
credentials or keys
however delightful your apis are if
developers cannot easily get access to
them
if they cannot easily understand how to
use them adoption will suffer
the apogee edge developer portal
addresses that need
via the portal api providers can publish
a catalog of api
products api consumers
developers of the apps that invoke the
apis can learn about the available apis
and begin using them so let's see it
working
first i'll assume the role of api
provider
sign in to apigee.com
click on this portals link plus portal
will create a new portal
name it clicking through i can manage
that portal
this page gives access to the theme the
portal pages
various settings and assets like images
and so on
but let's see what the portal looks like
we'll click on the live portal link
and see the sample this is what api
consumer developers would see
now this is just the sample you'll want
to change your portal let's flip back to
the administrative ui
once again assuming the role of api
publisher
let's make some quick changes first
the logo image
the hero image
a custom diagram
here i've uploaded only image assets you
can of course
add assets of other types
now the theme i have full control over
the css for the site
so you can brand it any way you like
i'll just paste my own css in
and publish that
some text for the home page
i'll publish that
text for the getting started page
and publish
okay let's see what we've got
that looks pretty good let's click
around here
we can see the getting started page
a link to support now in your portal you
can
define the menu here and the pages they
open
in this video you learn the basics of
api portals and the basics for styling
your portal and adding your own content
you can also publish apis to the portal
we haven't done that yet
that's a topic for the next video till
then
keep it digital